live from Kanaka in the heart of San
Diego this is screen junkies boobie
vines and now your hosts of movie bytes
how Rudnik and any signal are you ready
for an all-star movie fight we have
brought some of your favorites and some
of our best friends for a movement so
gracious to be on the show I hope
they're all back there and ready because
I'm calling you up now here we go guys
look who's gonna be fighting today
botanicals himself my Carlsbad ladies
and gentlemen put your hands together
for the one the only the Australian
Redbury
Alicia below he's part of the schmoes no
crew Marc
oh he's one of the inglorious bastards
make some noise
you guys see a little movie called
spider-man homecoming about flash pops -
Tony Laurie
[Applause]
this guy loves movies and he's super
funny make some noise for dog Benson
ladies and gentlemen oh here is dead the
mapper
[Applause]
and the current movie fights sham
Specter cowboy man that's hard to say
Dan how does that feel that's rough I
think that's the first time I've had to
do that live that hurts
I have something very damaging I can say
that's not to go work but I'm not going
to say it right now all right well let's
do this I'm so excited what a wonderful
panel they're going to be doing amazing
fights for you today first round I need
Mark Ellis and Amelie SH and Alicia
Malone mark and Alicia are first up yet
all right you guys ready round one
[Music]
Star Wars prequel or The Hobbit trilogy
mark what are you picking Andy you've
known me a long time you know I'm not
going to go against my religion and that
is Jedi Knight I am going to be
defending the Star Wars prequels ladies
and gentlemen Oh Alicia Malone that
means you'll be defending of it all
right now tell him how this works for
voting you guys are gonna listen okay so
everybody has a card it's a two-sided
card one is the screen junkie side one
is the screen junkie central side okay
yellow and white there we go yellow and
white okay the yellow will be for mark
the white will be for Alicia okay so
remember yellow for mark white for
Alicia so listen to the arguments people
and then you will help us decide who
moves on to the next round all right
guys you ready let's do this all right
Oh who wants to go first vote yellow
who's going first
awesome death marks going first there we
go go mark Andy both of these trilogies
have their issues for sure you got some
bad acting in there you got some
terrible dialogue and you have a lot of
overused green screen effects however
the Star Wars prequels are much much
better than the unnecessary Hobbit
prequels simply because the
star wars movies expanded the universe
and gave us a much richer mythology as
opposed to the Hobbit which took one
appendix and tried to expand it into a
boring nine hour long cash grab piece of
uselessness that taints the original
Lord of the Rings to some degree what
the Star Wars prequels gave us was
twofold
they gave us new characters and great
political intrigue and as an added bonus
yeah even if you don't think the Star
Wars prequels are great I don't think
they're that good they took us to a
place where Star Wars could now be
rescued again as opposed to the Hobbit
prequels which pretty much buried any
chance of us ever going back to
middle-earth George Lucas we thank you
wherever you may be all right Alicia
what's to say about that but I'll first
start with The Hobbit trilogy there's so
much to like about the holotropic
trilogy yes I agree that it was one book
that was stretched out into three movies
unnecessarily it could have just been
one self-contained film but when you
look at it there's so many good parts in
The Hobbit there are great performances
I love Martin Freeman there's likeable
characters and it's got a great quest
story it also is visually connected and
totally connected to the Lord of the
Rings trilogy so that wasn't jarring for
audiences and for fans it was great to
see that you know returned to
middle-earth so it didn't hurt the
original trilogy in any way and it just
gave us some extra backstory so there's
a lot to love within the Hobbit trilogy
the sum of its parts are actually pretty
damn good I would argue that 48 frames
makes me puke and that is what The
Hobbit movies gave us and you can have
some bad characters and annoying
characters Jar Jar Binks he's annoying
but I would rather have somebody attempt
a new character than have somebody take
what could have been a cool character
like smile and make him take a nap for
30 minutes in Scrooge McDuck ball if you
have good characters utilize them do not
waste them the movie was called the
desolation of Smaug and he snored first
35 minutes you talk about political
intrigue I remember a lot of hallways a
lot of conference rooms a lot of
unnecessarily those text chat at some
point was in Washington that is politics
the characters were not likable you have
Jar Jar Binks which you said but even
like Queen Amidala and Anakin Skywalker
and for me that is the worst part of the
Star Wars prequels is that they took
this character Darth Vader who is one of
the greatest movie villains of all time
and they made him kind of boring and not
interesting and they took away his
intrigue I mean do we need to hear that
he hates sand I mean kind of ruins it
it also grow in Hayden Christensen's
Korea sadly sadly for that all right
final closing thoughts guys again it's
about the arguments listen here closely
final thoughts mark yeah I mean if you
look at Darth Vader in the villain is
the prequels you're not going to get one
but Senator Palpatine turning into Darth
Sidious in the Emperor is really one of
the great turns that you've seen in
recent memory that is where the
political intrigue comes from he's
blowing a whole rope-a-dope over this
entire Republic and the Star Wars
prequels each movie gave us at least one
memorable scene there is nothing
memorable about any of the Hobbit movies
other than the fact that I wasted $45
going to see them you get a great
lightsaber fight with Darth Maul you get
a great lightsaber fight with some new
moves from Yoda
and then you have the epic battle that
we've been waiting for since 1977 seeing
Anakin lose the obi-wan because he had
the high ground just like I have in this
argument I was in kartalija well yeah it
had to wait so long Star Wars fans to
get more from the Star Wars universe and
when you did I mean it was so
disappointing and the fact that it
actually was inconsistent with the
trilogy there are things that they say
in the prequels that do not make sense
with the original trilogy that it feels
like George Lucas didn't even watch the
original trilogy again before he wrote
breakfast I say that the prequels
actually damage the original trilogy to
the point where when you have new Star
Wars films JJ Abrams had to go back to
the original trilogy to give fans what
they truly deserved in the first place
The Hobbit didn't ruin The Lord of the
Rings it has the dull moments I will
give you that but overall it was a
pretty damn good trilogy and I enjoyed
it it's based on wine time how what do
you think their help give them a round
of applause
they came out women all right it's
yellow for Ellis it's white firm alone
so hold up your cards oh that's hot oh
my god wow this is a close one yeah
there's a lot of yellow to yellow
thank you thank you we have gas on the
rim gap you have white in the middle I
think Alicia Malone take this round with
wash mr. Mark Allen Bravo so funny Thank
You Marc well played
Alicia moves on to the next round this
next battle is Mike Carlson hashtag
Botanica versus Cody rubble
alright guys let's see your fight round
two better overall movie franchise one
x-men or spider-man
what the heck Andy Tony what are you
going to pick mmm I'm taking spider-man
Oh
Mike Carlson that means you'll be
picking x-men very good yeah I thought
he was singing spider-man 2 all right
Tony time begins now what's let you
start oh okay well spider-man is
superior film everything I mean the
character itself has better villains has
better everything really the x-men is a
boring told out tale and spider-man is
way more relatable than any other
character in any comic book franchise
that's why is the most popular superhero
all around the world um okay where to
start first of all I relate to the beast
he's a tortured genius he's very smart
he makes quips
he loves show - OH - spider-man yeah but
it's a little different yeah cuz he's
funnier that's true
spider-man is funnier than the Beast but
that's not what we're talking about
folks here's the thing this is an even
matchup Tony and I I of respect and I
like my opponent very much like life and
it I'd like yes that's that friendship
and sportsmanship
that's Obama and McCain I like yes it is
so here's the thing
we both have superhero Hollywood
experience Tony of course is Flash
Thompson in the new spider-man and I got
a callback for a guardians of the galaxy
Dairy Queen commercial rookie
and then there's a whole thing but I did
not book it I didn't get I'm sorry to
say that I am I kind of mixed you you
were in it and I died you have that much
sway in a Marvel organization that you
can get commercial actors taken out of
more commercials you're a mill cutter
alright let's move all right that's
always there IRB let's stay on topic
movie here and i'm kenny hook v it took
five movies to get a peter parker that
we actually liked and felt correct okay
don't boo that Tobey Maguire was a big
wiener
you know what fruit is like MJ MJ you're
so beautiful I'm not gonna [ __ ] you like
okay I almost don't want to fight this
for that reason because Jenny's in the
audience and I know she loves Toby way
more but first off the spider-man
original trilogy yes with Sam Raimi set
the precedent for all other movies all
movie is the superhero I think
battleship potemkin might actually be if
we're talking all moving terms of
superhero movie vitamin 2 is still
considered one of the best Bible what my
favorite movie Superman 20 years earlier
x-men was earlier in series I'm not
allowed to comment on them that's fair
but I'm talking about in the in the
Marvel Universe while Fox has
continually tried tripping themselves
over and over to try to get this story
right now finally we have spider-man
homecoming please please clap if you've
seen the movie
very much which is one of the
highest-rated superhero movies to date I
saw the bomb a token Russell Tommy I
know
Vera lady to Russ first of all they're
on Tomatoes fatty Ford it doesn't really
make sense
thank you for Andrew Garfield all right
he's like handsome hot spider-man we
don't want that that's not relatable and
if you're looking let's hope yes he's
well look I want I love I love watching
those movies you know why I love
watching the x-men movies they're good
yes sleep they put me to sleep no shot
fired there look there's like six
spider-man movies and there's three
different spider-man actors that's not a
good sign for who different actors
playing Professor X and Magneto and the
B just prefer you as the only one
playing the same character humans is
Hugh Jackman yeah you hadn't been do
Horne in every single movie he's been
Wolverine a tech can you imagine if like
every two movies Wolverine with a
different guy
like all of a sudden Stephen Dorff is
Wolverine like okay can you explain the
x-men a timeline can you explain all
that because that's just so convoluted
all right well you this is your got to
wrap it up your lack however you want to
claim yeah well over 30 more minutes of
information to give sorry they only give
us so much time here that's it up with
the closing arguments mic through that
he's right that was part of it first
here's the thing folks well not only do
we have excellent movies that are really
great we have two spin-off movies that
are really great we have Logan we have
Deadpool Sony is going to make like a
silver sable movie because there's like
they don't even have control of their
own characters like this is how in
shambles this franchise is okay x-men
has at a rich universe of characters and
they're being explored very
interestingly like with different genres
and in different types by interesting
filmmakers spider-man homecoming is
great but it took like 15 years to
finally go oh good spider-man
now I know mental thoughts I know so
many people who went to go see the
original spider-man series including
myself and loved those films and I
remember those films fondly way more
than I do the x-men series and
spider-man homecoming that's all I'm
going to say you have Flash Thompson you
have a character screaming out penis
Parker and can I can I get the audience
to help me out here when I say penis you
say Parker ready penis exactly my point
mate yeah I don't got Wow oh my was that
Dairy Queen commercial cannon yeah okay
so yeah Tony bringing in the crowd work
interesting take their butt yeah let's
see what the votes are - all right nowI
based on argument these the yellow
screen junkies central site for Tony's a
white screen junkie side for Mike yellow
for Tony white four Mike Oh looks like
Mike Carlson takes it well played
gentlemen and there's the boss mr. Tony
run boy Bravo you're doing just fine sir
oh this is an all celebrity all-star
matchup just Benson versus Sam Levine
alright time for round three
worst movie character to cosplay as
sitting here at comic-con you guys are
going to tell us what would be the
what's the worst one not going to put it
up on the screen like that last one
yours right there dark it's in front of
each other two choices oh no no now
you're going to give it I want I was
really looking forward to seeing their
reaction to seeing both of them at the
same time here we go alright Sam Levine
want to tell us what you're picking sure
it's a pretty clear option Johnny Storm
I don't even have to make an argument
they've all figured it out
Doug Benson who are you picking I got
one has got even less of a need for an
argument than Johnny Storm the human
centipede
all right this should be interesting
this let's start with two here hi my god
that it was going to be a younger crowd
yep yeah let's be careful I get labels
on it in family crowd Sam Levine all
right Human Torch Johnny Storm versus
the human I mean the bottom line kids
just don't set yourself on fire or do
the other thing yeah these are both
terrible terrible ideas but I guess I
have to start so thank you very much
good luck just in Westham and I'm going
to need it really I'm just spinning my
wheels up here for the next three
minutes guys we know this is going to
end so you don't have to fill the time
we can get out of here earlier really
good couldn't we I guess I'll make it
quick if you go Johnny storm the Human
Torch everybody knows there is no good
way to replicate fire it doesn't look
good in CG and it looks a hell of a lot
worse if you try to make up a flaming
costume so realistically your only
option is to actually set yourself on
fire and while it might be an awesome
cosplay idea it would be an awesome
cosplay idea for about 12 seconds and
then you're dead so if this is your
sayonara move if you are a kamikaze
cosplayer then this is the greatest
costume but for the rest of us this is a
terrible idea because you're either
going to embarrass yourself with a bad
look or you're going to self emulate and
people are going to think this was some
sort of religious sacrifice ceremony and
not care about your cause and then
you're just going to be a laughingstock
all right done well you know here at
comic-con
if you're on fire people get out of your
way just imagine how difficult it would
be to get around if you were two or more
people attached to each other via your
mouth and a noose you know I watched
that Oh Jade parole thing the other day
and it went on for way too long
so I like to speed this up and end my
argument with the human centipede
all right well closing arguments then I
don't really like to admit this but I
was part of a human centipede once for
about eight months and I got to tell you
there is someone Pleasant parts but I
did a lot of growing and a lot of
learning and I think if you put yourself
in a human centipede cosplay yeah you
might get some dirty looks it might be a
little cumbersome to get around but
afterward you're going to be grateful to
the experienced Human Torch you're in
debt that's the end of your learning
advice final thoughts are you done no I
have another thought
I'm very excited to hear it
I like Tobey Maguire better than Andrew
Garfield how about a human centipede of
Tobey Maguire and Carville and Tom
Holland I would line up yeah not watch
that gets the end all right I've had
from crapping that now all right pal
help me out okay
we're going to have yellow side for Sam
white side for Doug yellow for Sam white
for Doug
it looks closed it was closer than I
thought human centipede does Benson Hey
see you later
moving on out of applause mr. Sam Levine
Bravo that was fun all right next up all
I'm so excited for this there's a
rivalry brewing if you haven't been
watching Lee fights lately this man took
the other man's belt away
ladies and gentlemen Spencer Gilbert the
champion and Dan Merrill
and this is an exhibition match the belt
is not on that's not on the line here
all it can't be a submission right now
belts can't cut the rules say the belts
can't be on the line at the cons they
have to be in studio no belts on the
line at the Colin see what happens here
the fans the fans will deal where is the
bell it's safe to enter camp Spencer
leaves the belt like it's like in the
corner of offices okay ring that you got
it oh baby I get off so much
Spencer J Gilbert keeps the championship
belt between his desk and the wall
Spencer Shay Gilbert forgot the belt and
had to have our producer bring it
tonight and you still didn't win all
right all right I can't wait there's
some heat coming here round four what's
more powerful the force or the Hulk Wow
all right Spencer what are you pickin I
mean the force Dan I mean you're taking
the Hulk of course I'm taking a hold all
writing me Spencer you want to start us
well okay I mean to quote Han Solo I'm
not sure that's how the force works The
Hulk can't punch the force right it's a
material it's like the war on terror
it's like it's like an idea you can't
punch it you can't punch terror so I
think he's going to do disadvantage
right up off the bat but I guess to make
this interesting we should make it like
a Jedi right like a Jedi versus Hulk
thing
sure so who do you want Yoda you want
obi-wan you want penis head you could
pick whichever jumpiness that means yes
you said it is the Hulk against the Jedi
with the penis shaped head from the
prequels you guys know much about right
y'all know penises we all know penis
head did you know Joe knows his name yes
something Mundy oh that's ironic okay so
Deena's head Jedi verse the Hulk
sure okay on a physical level I think he
can at least neutralize them because you
can use telekinesis you can levitate the
Hulk where he can't really get any grip
anywhere a lightsaber could arguably go
through his head you can decapitate the
Hulk that's one way to take them out and
you can um you can
welcome we've seen the Hulk almost
drowned and that's something that could
bring them back down to Bruce Banner but
most importantly the Hulk has a glaring
weakness and that is people can get in
his big dumb green head so easily short
list of people who have mind-control the
hope Loki the Scarlet Witch you've got
Jennifer Connelly as Betty Ross you've
got Liv Tyler as Betty Ross you've got
Scarlett Johansson just basically doing
a Jedi mind trick Oh another bye lullaby
and bam he takes a big green nap all
right Dan well you didn't pick any of
those beautiful women you pick [ __ ]
and that was your move not mine so
lettings night head it's not better than
Jennifer Connelly secondly Scarlet Witch
mind-controlled Bruce Banner not The
Hulk and we're talking about the Hulk
they say this is the Jedi mind trick
this is the Hulk you're talking about
and you're right the Hulk can't punch
the force but the Hulk can punch the
[ __ ] out of a Jedi and that's exactly
what he's going to do have you seen you
didn't even pick Yoda the most powerful
Jedi again that was a mistake on your
part Yoda the most powerful Jedi at the
height of his power a rock fell from the
ceiling he's like Oh God get out of here
I can't hold this rock The Hulk is like
a hundred times denser a hundred times
thicker and a thousand times more
motivated than a rock falling from the
ceiling so this is not going to hold the
host back this is going to get the Hulk
even angrier and what do we know about
the Hulk the matter Hulk gets beef
stronger Hulk is hashtag eight words
that is an answer my friend you can slow
down the hole but you cannot stop him
yeah the Hulk doesn't get mad at Yoda or
penis head I'm sorry there's nothing
more tranquil and calming than a prequel
era Jedi nothing puts you to sleep
faster the dumb guy cross-legged with a
lightsaber sitting around the table
talking about that is not going to make
Hulk mad that is going to make Hulk
sleep that is going to make holes walk
up to that dome hologram chair and punch
him through the war the floor the Jedi
Council chamber you keep deflecting like
oh yeah no no they're not going to fight
not going to fight because you know that
the holes not going to lose the fight
against the force it's what's more
powerful not what's more boring not
what's more easy not what what puts
people to sleep what's more powerful
than Hulk is the unstoppable force the
Hulk is the EM movable object you can
deflect and talk around the fight but
this is a question about what's more
powerful and you don't have an ant and
why is she home get heated by Scarlet
Witch and Loki with their little handle
EVP again Bruce Banner not the whole
economy help my friend turning the only
way to defeat the Hulk is to turn him
back into Bruce Banner that's happened
over and over and over again
Ironman did it by punching him a couple
times he even turned back into Bruce
Banner from falling from a helicopter
thing in Avengers right did that happen
yeah he passed out all right your final
thought Spencer Jedi bring balance to
the force the Hulk's full of rage
they'll see him coming they'll get in
his head he's done Dan final thoughts I
think that he knows that in a one-on-one
fight the Hulk is going to win the day
he's deflecting he's talking about all
this is this is a Nash trick this is a
technicality I'm saying that the host
will soundly defeat any Jedi see her the
Hulk is more powerful the Jedi the
lightsaber can't penetrate his skin you
can't cut off his head you can't choke
him because the jet is going to try to
choke them it's going to go up against
that whole skin and it's not going to
cut off his airway this is what's more
powerful the force of the whole Spencer
can dance around at all that he wants
you can talk about Scarlet Witch and
mind wavy powers and girlfriends and are
you going garlic Johansson but he cannot
prove that the force is more powerful
than the Hulk and that is what I have
proved I have proof nothing Hulk it's
more power from the force that is the
question being asked and I rest my case
Wow Wow Admiral breaking out the Dane
Cook stage strut all right so yellow for
Dan white for Spencer
it's like Danville
unstoppable let's hear it for both of
our combatants oh man all right the fans
want you to get that belt back then all
right
that's now we're back to round five our
two previous winners are going to come
back here ladies and gentlemen let's
bring back up Alicia Malone and Mike
Carlson red
jury versus hashtag Botanica all right
round five what superheroes powers what
you leased what to have in real life I
feel like I misread the question when I
looked at the email oh yeah let me tell
me why let me tell you what my answer
was it said what superpower would you
want to have least and I said to
immediately comprehend legal documents I
think that would come in handy like I
can't do that now because that all right
well Leisha you get you want to say
yours first
I'm going with Professor X oh you would
least one him okay Mike Carlson
can I pick from the 1996 x-men comic
series maggot you'll have to yeah you'll
have to educate us all I'd love to okay
so you're abandoning the legal documents
can I do the legal documents because
it's not a superhero who does not it's
not it I made it up pick a superhero
yeah mega we're doing magnet okay all
right I'll explain who maggot is Lane
maggot all right only should us start
yeah yeah I don't know how I'm gonna
count two up anyway so I would least
likely I would least like to have these
powers of Professor X because he is so
powerful that he has the ability to hurt
many people and ability to hurt himself
and in Logan you know will given a very
broken older Wolverines but the saddest
figure of all was Charles Xavier I mean
he is locked in the shell of his own
brain he killed all the mutants he emits
horrible seizures he does not have a
good life at all and I think you know at
the height of his powers it would be so
annoying to hear all the voices all the
time plus you hear everyone's troubles
and it's so much weight to carry
it'd be like plugged into Twitter or
anyway just hearing all the thoughts and
I would just go crazy so I would not
like to have the powers of Professor he
put the thing is he could win at poker
really easily and like he could do so
many cool things now it's maggot he
could certainly do that maggot is a
character from the Joe matter or Scott
Lobdell run of uncanny x-men are their
fans out there of this I was raised on
this maggot was a character that his
digestive system came out of his body in
the form of two maggots that were made
out of metal that was his power and then
he would send the maggots after people
this is a nightmare folks if anyone here
has had just minor bowel problems you
know this would be crazy I mean this guy
first of all he can lose the maggots the
maggots can go away and then he can't
digest food so imagine you're fighting a
super villain the maggots are attacking
like let's say you know magneto they
latch on to magneto magneto goes back to
asteroid em you can't eat dinner it's
horrible meanwhile professor yeah sure
there's some dangerous stuff to it but
the thing is like all the good stuff I
feel like outweighs the bad you know
like you know what people are thinking
you know who likes you you know who you
should put on your enemies list okay
sometimes you're like you know I think
that that bank teller doesn't like me
and then you if you a professor expert
you be like oh yeah they don't like me
you would write it down and then when
you want another murder rampage you
would kill them ha ha ha Alysha horrible
so I was just getting some lowdown on
maggot because I've never heard but so
one of their powers and abilities is
psychometric power enables him to draw
psychic imprints from his environment
replaying in his mind's eye events which
once took place or will soon take place
in general vicinity that sounds pretty
good that sounds like a useful job with
a magical power yes the magnets are
horrible it would be unsightly and it
would be really annoying but I think
with Professor X he just has such a
unwieldy power that is could be used for
good but could also really be turned
against him you see the toll it took on
his own body and the toll it took on his
friends and then to hear people
all the time I would not like to know if
the bank teller doesn't like me or not
that's like YouTube comments you know I
don't I don't read the YouTube comments
anymore that I want to hear people to
think I'm pretentious or whatever
apparently they do so I would not want
to hear whatever I'm thinking all the
time about I know thought Mike hello
folks do you hate waiting in line at the
supermarket yeah like I do I hate it
Professor X can do that thing where he
stops time what I would do is I would go
to the supermarket I would do go do all
my shopping I would bring a calculator
and I would add up everything I would
freeze the store I would leave some cash
on the counter guilt free
yep the line baby professor X can do
things like mundane stuff that would
make your life so much better stuff that
would cut down on time so you could get
back to whatever it is you want to do
watch Netflix or masturbate or whatever
you do Alicia OS X also count wall keep
strapped to the wheel check he has to
have his helmet on a lot of times it's a
power that's not just useful it's
actually really damaging and it's hard
to control and we saw what happened with
jean grey and that could it basically
happen with breasts as well baguette
sounds like it's annoying and probably
the most useless superhero power that I
can think of but it doesn't sound like
the one I was least likely to have I
just want want to kill everyone or to
hear bad thoughts all the time I am
alright which superpower would you like
to have least yellow for my Carlson
white for Alicia Malone oh this is a
barnburner
oh they team them up a lot of yellow
yellow Mike Carlton fake alright Flo
magnet for the win the prize didn't see
that coming
a round of applause for the red clay
Mike Carlson was here in the file all
right next up Doug Benson versus Dan
Moreau all right time for round six all
right make a movie better by swapping
out the lead with groot dan what are you
picking the happening all right
Doug Benson I'm going to go with the the
plants of fire starring Vin Diesel I
like this one all right good call you
guys all right Dan you wanna start yes
the happening is a disaster of a movie I
don't know how it was made it kind of
goes wrong at every turn and I was
thinking about this question and I
thought if you replace Mark Wahlberg
with Groot that movie becomes about
group finding his place in the world
he's a schoolteacher kind of lost in
society and he slowly kind of returns to
nature and learns to commune with his
fellow trees and it kind of ends with
him making peace and accepting his place
in nature and society in the forest and
there are so many scenes that work
better when you just replace the dialog
the the Mark Wahlberg lines that don't
make any sense like the old lady's thing
like planning to kill me in my sleep
instead of mark dialog just like doing
though or not he just I am Groot
and literally everything is like like
like hotdogs don't you I am Groot like
that movie works so much better with
Groot
so that was my favorite did Boogie
Nights with Mark Wahlberg pulled his
dick out looked in the mirror went I am
Groot I mean it could be any Vin Diesel
vehicle but the pacifier really seems to
me to be the one where if it was Groot
instead of Vin Diesel it would only
improve the movie in the sense that he
doesn't have a lot of dialogue anyway
and he sort of grumbles all the time and
it would be fun to watch a tree trying
to take care of a baby I I feel like
watching the pacifier I felt like I was
watching a tree take care of a baby I
did I just imagine the last thing that
happening which is so disappointing when
like they would have been an excellent
twist
if it turned out that the science
teacher was a tree what that's why you
figured out that the trees were killing
everyone that scene that scene where
Mark Wahlberg's talking to a plastic
tree makes so much more sense that
that's Groot and then at the end when
they're just standing in the field and
like it just stops for no reason
he just says we are Groot
it makes so much more sense you guys are
closer dan closing thought I could just
see the scene the past fire where he's
trying to change the diaper there's been
everywhere and he walked out the door
and on his way out he grabs his coat he
says I'm group cuz crew wouldn't stick
around and change his shitty baby I'm
just impressed you both saw the pacifier
alright how what time in prime good
press the sword I'm so glad I can
finally get out of here right yellow for
Dan white for Doug yeah wears it and
takes it around you I love that's great
alright Dan yes
Mike Carlson come on back the final now
best comic book movie performance let me
mix different things
dan what are you picking I picked Heath
Ledger as the Joker in the Dark Knight
Mike Carlson what are you picking
animalist as Batman Oh what is aw I mean
I know he's dead but they're not they're
both not here so either of you can use
that in your argument all right why
would I yeah what a terrible thing
didn't everyone said oh no talking about
celebrate these wonderful performance
all over alright we're going to really
walk around this for the get let's use
the space Mike alright like a tea is
like a Dane Cook concert
all right Daniel s startup yeah I'll
start until I get to walk around the
audience or something all right
camera guys love this okay uh yeah Heath
Ledger's The Joker
there's it's not about Adam West is
great and Christopher Reeve Superman so
many great comic book movie performances
but I think there's a reason why Heath
Ledger and I think that one stands out
first of all it broke kind of broke
through that mold and was recognized
legitimately by the Academy by the
Golden Globes I personally think that
that would have happened no matter what
because that was such a brilliant
performance and you have to imagine like
Heath Ledger's that roles the Joker
you're living under such a shadow
even though way to come out a long time
ago of Jack Nicholson who a lot of
people thought owned that character and
Mark Hamill who we all grew up with as
the Batman animated series Joker at
Cesar Romero people loved the Adam West
thing and for Heath Ledger to come out
and completely reinvent that role and do
it in a way that nobody saw coming to
make it such a compelling character -
you know people kind of thought that the
Joker laughs and you know who that
character is and he completely just took
that boundary and made that character
even more complex and interesting than I
certainly thought it could be so for me
the best kind of performance has to be
somebody that took the character and did
something that I didn't think about even
though it had been trotting over so many
times and that's why it shows ledger all
right Mike folk Adam when Batman
1966 this is actually the thing that
started at all this is a thing that
brought a literal comic book to life
it's colorful it is fun it has
adventures it's funny it is still if you
look at it the funniest of any of these
movies there are lines like some days
you just can't get rid of a bomb there's
a scene where they're on a pier and and
Robin asks why why they saved all the
drunks in there and Batman goes so they
may be drinkers Robin but they're also
human beings
this is a movie that literally does
everything and it starts it off it's
almost impossible there was no template
for this before there was not a ton of
movies in TV the Heath Ledger is great
but this is on the backs of so many
different people so many different
performances so many different takes
taking all of them and synthesizing it
which is great it's an amazing
performance Adam one starts out in this
Batman he makes first of all it works on
every level as a kid I thought this show
was bit serious this is the funny and
silly a show but I was like I believe
this guy I believe he's earnest and he
cares and when he tells Robin that we
have to put money into a parking meter I
thought that was a good lesson I bought
all of it and now as an adult I I see it
as a fun adventure and I also see it as
one of the funniest if not my favorite
comedy shows and superhero shows of all
time that all of this stuff would be
different if it weren't for Adam West
and this TV show well I don't think Adam
West has really saddled with a lot of
baggage with Batman because there have
been some serials and stuff but Batman
on film and TV he was kind of the first
mainstream guy so he got to kind of do
what he wanted and I love Adam West I
think Adam West is hilarious
and he's hilarious at playing that Adam
West character and that's what I feel
like he did his Batman I'm not saying
that's a bad character but I'm saying he
played to his strengths he did a role
that didn't really have a lot of baggage
attached to it and and he did it so well
but I think that that take kind of a lot
of people thought that was Batman and I
don't know what Batman
but it's my Batman that's your Batman I
don't know if it's everyone's Batman I
love letting Batman but when we're
looking at best performance I had to
look at you know when they when they say
Heath Ledger is going to do the Joker
nobody thinks the guy can do it
everyone's like oh that guy's a nice
tail guy I won him this is Joey King he
can't do this like he's a serious
dramatic actor but he's not going to be
able to do this he's never shown as he
could do anything like that and he
excelled every metric that people had
down put for him he excelled to the
point where he reinvented the character
he could have fallen back and done Jack
Nicholson he could have fallen back and
done any number of takes on the
character I think that is a better
performance because he transcended
expectation he had a lot of weight on
his shoulders to do this role and he did
far better than anyone could have
acceded to the point that he was the
thing that people remember most about
that movie more than Batman
so Adam West is great I think that he
played that Adam West character and
family guys like to through the end and
it was great and everybody loved it but
if we look at the best performance it's
the guy that reached that stretch that
did the most of the character and for me
that's ledger I think when you're
looking at performance though you can
argue that Adam West and his style of
deadpan is something that that
transcends and then influences comedy
for the next 50 years when we're talking
about performance but not is not just
superhero movies you look at Leslie
Nielsen when he didn't take a gun it's a
very similar straight face delivery of
comedy it's this is a guy who influenced
a lot of things more than just
superheroes Ledger again great but it's
sort of an anomaly because this guy was
so talented he really locked into
something Adam West influenced a an
entire generation of people and
filmmakers and it's and later on when
people realized hey I don't want to
still around all of a sudden at Seth
MacFarlane put him on the cartoon Conan
O'Brien made an amazing pilot with him
called Luke well if you've ever seen
this it's the funniest in the world it's
yes
four people saw it but anyway I think
that you have to give this credit
because this Batman performance comes
out of nowhere there's nothing before it
it starts it it would be very easy to
put anybody else in there and have them
that up there's this one man there was
no one else who can do that there is no
other actor I can think of that can
deliver exactly on all of the things
I've talked about as brother other than
Adam West all right I just get a tough
one out just 10 seconds each final recap
at all your final thought listen this
cuz I need your vote this isn't stuff
Dan wrap it up Batman
was a campy TV show it was written campy
and it was performed Camp Lee and was
performed well Camp Lee by Adam West he
fit into the role if they asked him to
play which is that they all knew that
this was a joke and they played it dead
serious and that's that's an admirable
approach for that show but I don't think
it defined the character and I don't
think that a lot of people consider that
the definitive performance of Batman nor
did it have to be it didn't have that
expectation Heath Ledger came in and he
took a role that everybody said couldn't
be done better in any medium they said
this has been done before what is this
guy going to bring to it we don't think
he can do it and he was by far I think
the most memorable out of all of them
and the way that you say that
to find Batman I think he defined Batman
for a certain generation I think that
Heath Ledger's Joker defined the current
crop of comic book movies as far as tone
and execution better than the sixties
Adam West Batman Mike Carlson quickly
laughs aw I think Heath Ledger's bike
being brilliant I think and in the comic
culture we value dark and gritty a
little bit too much he is a great Joker
but in the wake of that we've gotten a
bunch of different like hot topic type
Joker like that is what the influence is
like we've got now Jared Leto and he's
got a girl like in the wake of that we
haven't seen anyone come close in the
wake of Adam West
we saw comedy we saw other superhero
movies this actually becoming the first
superhero made it seem possible
like everything else would not have
happened if it weren't for him and the
ability to sell and do what I said where
he was he is funny he is serious he is
believable he is the ultimate crime
fighter and as a kid as an adult you
admire you look up to and you laugh at
this man he is incredible there you have
it here for both all right
yellow for Dan white for Mike oh wow
[Music]
[Applause]
they are burning I had three margaritas
before those guys I'm going to call it a
time whoa posture call and these guys
are too tired to do it again you know
you're sharing it what do you think I'm
kidding I'm giving you a speed round Wow
if it's written over 1000 I'm going to
be okay we can't have a tie on movie
fight guys you will have 30 seconds each
are you ready
well what character would you most would
be most fun to hang out with at
comic-con amen
Mike the dude what character be most fun
to hang out with a comic-con we have
ant-man the dude you will have 30
seconds Dan
time starts when you begin speaking yes
I'll give you ten second rebuttals
ant-man's the funny guy he's got quips
plus you can shrink down you can play
some great pranks with them you can
shrink down you can strip people it's
going to be fun it's going to be a lot
of good time
Plus these ant-man and who would be more
fun to hang out with a comic-con than
freakin ant-man who wouldn't want to
meet you and ant-man the dude is going
to be here for 10 minutes and want to
leave and go drink White Russians and
smoke weed ins littering we hate being
out in society hates people he wants to
be alone in his house or bowling the
last place he wants to be is at
comic-con do you know how paranoid this
place would make the dude he'd be high
as a kite surrounded by a hundred
thousand people it's a nightmare he'd be
miserable
Mike 30 seconds do you go to comic-con
to pull pranks on people
is that a thing you do a comic-con well
can't man you'd shrink down like I don't
know I don't know what that would do
like you would get away from things like
I what the power the dude here's the
thing what's going to happen he's gonna
walk on the floor you look at a couple
couple racks of comics and you go hey
let's go to the Joe's Crab Shack behind
the convention center and then you guys
by the way did you know there's a Joe's
Crab check behind the convention center
it's there and it's amazing you go back
there and you'd have a shark bite which
is the thing where they pour a different
colored liquid in the alcohol and they
go out of sharks in the water you'd have
a second dance you subscribe literally
everything but having fun at comic-con I
want to go to comic-con as a superhero
what for fun to go to comic-con with an
actual superhero I don't care about
Joe's Crab Shack and go eat that by my
hotel there's literally one next door to
my hotel right now I don't have to come
down to San Diego to eat at Joe's Crab
Shack with a guy that's high ten seconds
Mike I love comic-con but it is
exhausting you want a guy who's willing
to go chill out with you for a while you
don't want to go with a superhero he's
going to get mopped and it'll be a
nightmare everybody likes Ant Man here
he's the biggest celebrity the dude you
just walk over you'll chill and you be
like hey man you want to smoke a joint
yes I'm Wow all right this debate
brought to you by Joe's Crab Shack I'm
glad we got that plug in I was worried
we wouldn't all right yellow for Dad
white for Mike
[Music]
dan Merle takes it mo congratulations
how about a rap one microphone we get
all our fighters back up Sam Levine
Doug Benson did he leave by the Tony
Revell Laurie come on up here Alicia
Malone Marvin up that rubber tail here
come on up for a quick thank you and
round of applause for all our amazing
fighters before we jump into this dick
spit want to get a quick photo how about
these guys
Bravo
where's our camera fur where's our
manual you're up there you'll get a good
shot all right round of applause work
back Bobby fine thank you line I'm a
wonderful time